it's the beginning of June the beginning
of summer effectively for us academics
and it's time for me to do another
update video so what I'm going to do is
talk about all the things that took
place in May and what we've got coming
up in June before we do that I like to
do some highlights so the three big
things coming up for this month is in
the beginning of the month actually just
days from now I'm going to be traveling
up to the Institute for Saint Anselm
studies at st. Anselm College where I
will be doing a summer research
residency splitting my time in part
between doing some work for the
Institute and some of my own research
and some filming i'll talk more about
that later camping it off with a very
fun conference that i like to go to
every year when i can another big thing
that happened was in maine we passed the
two thousand subscribers mark and i
created a video specifically about that
thanking my viewers and subscribers once
again thanks and it got a lot of
interesting trashin and discussion i
think i'm going to do some some further
not necessarily video but but some
writing about that in the future i'm
also going to be in some respects
scaling back to to some degree on the
video production and blogging the
blogging i haven't done that much so
it's not that big of a scale back i'm
going to be releasing about four videos
per week as opposed to the the typical
526 in part because i need to spend more
time on research and writing in part
because i'm going to be taking some
well-deserved family time break but i
will be doing about four videos per week
and i'll talk about those when we get to
the june part so a month of May was a
like every month very busy I did two
talks one of which was online so let me
talk about that one first I have a
colleague down in South Carolina who
teaches high school history AP History
and who also does a lot
prepped videos for that some really high
production stuff very entertaining but
also a lot of information there that's
Tom Ritchie and he asked me to come on
and do a Q&A session for his viewers
about modern European philosophy so that
covers a lot of area it went very well I
enjoyed it Tom enjoyed it I think the
viewer is enjoyed it quite a bit you can
see the video over in his channel if you
happen to miss it and I think we'll
probably doing more we'll probably be
doing more collaborations like that in
the future I'm hoping that we'll do some
stuff specifically on Hagel I also did a
talk in the library series that's been
ongoing the fifth one form a was on the
Stoics so you know early stoics but
primarily the later stoics like Seneca
Epictetus and Marcus Aurelius and their
views on anger they were one of the main
rivals to the Aristotelian school when
it came to that emotion and their
viewpoint on it ended up not only you
know bearing fruit for stoics but also
for eclectic philosophers like like
Cicero and even ended up influence and
quite a bit of Christian thought on
anger later on as we're going to see as
we move through this series so videos
for those are available my teaching has
been on the one hand coming to a close
for the marist class which you know
pretty thankful about the world views
and values class finished up although I
do have some students who took in
completes that I still have to follow up
with a lot of medical and completes this
time around even to the level that that
the Dean raised some questions about it
but I also finished up just well it's
now I'm completely finished up but it's
close to finished up the GES
philosophical foundations class that
went very well we covered a number of
different areas of philosophy we had our
last video conferencing session we do
two hours a week of video conferencing
with me providing a presentation a lot
of discussion
that's the way the GTS classes work a
lot of work for me on both of those
classes you know producing videos
producing content handouts engaging with
the students and discussion forums a lot
of reading for me as well but very
productive experiences I think for my
students I also engaged in in a bit of
consulting and quite a bit of
philosophical counseling a little bit of
tutoring this this last month those are
some some of the areas that that I work
in almost entirely except for the
consulting part almost entirely through
the medium of the internet you know
using skype so that's that's good I also
did get the reason I owe website built
down a little bit more with the
philosophical counseling parts of people
who are interested in that sort of thing
can go to the website and see what it
entails and if they think that it's
something that they're interested in in
pursuing with me they can contact me I
got some work done on writing projects
not as much as i would like but i never
get as much done as i would like some
additional writing on st. handsome
getting ready for moving up to the the
institute some work on Gabrielle Marcel
and the Christian philosophy debates for
a long promised article for the
Gabrielle Marcel society's new journal I
didn't finish it which I you know a
little bit unhappy about but but it's
it's I've made some progress on itself
that's good and I started laying the
groundwork for my conference paper on
Thomas Aquinas and anger that we'll talk
about in the June part now videos the
half hour Hagel project passed another
milestone as I talked about in one of my
previous update videos and I'm now
committed to shooting six videos per
month which is quite a bit because each
one of those half hour videos takes
about five to six hours of time you know
between writing out the slides recording
the material doing all the editing
involved there's there's quite a bit
behind it
not to mention actually rereading the
Hagel and thinking about how am I
actually going to teach this but I'm
very happy too you know that there's
enough support for me to keep doing that
I've got a pretty devoted you know
viewership you could say and for the
half hour Hagel Patrian patrons I've
been able to provide some special perks
available to them if you're interested
in that sort of thing and in supporting
it you can you can see the link in the
video description so I did I did six
half hour Hagel videos this month we
finished up the section perception and
we launched into one of the sections
that's viewed as a particularly
difficult one by Hagel scholars force in
the understanding we are you know a good
ways into it I don't think we're at
quite the halfway mark but we're making
some good progress with that I think
will probably finish up with it in late
June early July I released the last of
the world views and values videos the
videos that I created from my marist
world views and values class and which
i'll be using as well for an eclair no
class that'll be an expanded version
that i'll be teaching that down the line
those were all on marks and they had
suspicions that suspicious lee
surprisingly well it was a little bit
suspicious given that i thought i would
have a lot of negative reactions but
surprisingly good comments on them
people really enjoyed that there i guess
there is kind of a lack of decent work
on marks in youtube and people have been
asking if I would shoot some more marks
related stuff and the answer is yes but
but not right now perhaps down the line
I also was able to get some some
critical thinking fallacy videos done
and to make some progress you know we're
not anywhere near finished with that
series I would like to get that series
finished so I can move on to other
topics and critical thinking in that
channel but it's you know that takes
quite a bit of work as
well because I have to create the slides
for those that that's pretty
time-consuming and then I have to shoot
and add it quite a bit for those videos
but they're getting quite a bit of use
and traction and good comments so that's
good I managed to finally put together
the video for the talk on humility that
I did back in April is humility advice
or a virtue and it released that and the
stoicism on anger talk you can also see
the video for that as well as all of the
other previous videos in the
understanding anger series so the acts
may quite a bit that that went on during
during that month what do we got going
on in June well let me talk first about
the research residency that I'm going to
be doing so I'm going up to New
Hampshire to st. Anselm College a place
that I've been connected with in one way
or another for about 15 years I went to
the very first scene handsome conference
back in two thousand where I presented a
paper as a graduate student and got to
meet some people who would end up being
very instrumental in my own development
as a scholar I talked about that in one
of my other videos that I'll link to
hear about becoming a saint anselm
scholar and I continued going to those
conferences when I when I could
sometimes you know it wasn't feasible to
do so but in most cases i did I was
asked to give the Saint Anselm lecture
which is a great honor in 2008 and I you
know I read my paper there I guess I'll
probably linked to that as well if
you're interested in that sort of thing
and I've continued my relationship with
them since then I did another research
residency a number of years back and
what that allowed me to do is to go and
use the special collection to you know
spend some time just focused on that
also to spend some time at the monks
because st. Anselm's college is actually
also a Benedictine monastery so I was
able to you know do the Liturgy of the
hours with them and talk with with
the monks about that different things
not too much about seeing Ansel bit more
about Benedict in life and it was a
really great time so I'm looking forward
to this I will be doing some work for
the Institute they actually have a
research project for me that they want
me to help out with in part because you
know they need somebody who actually
knows the field and knows the literature
and it's something to do the groundwork
in cattle cataloging dissertations and
finding information about that I'm happy
to do it because I am you know a big
supporter of the Institute and its
mission and I love seeing people doing
research on st. Anselm because I think
he's a really great thinker I will also
be doing some work on my own a good
portion of it is getting my conference
paper ready for a conference later this
summer in Boston reading and some where
i'll be presenting a paper specifically
on st. Anselm's prayers and meditations
and the workings of justice and mercy in
those I may actually have been working
on that project for quite some time I
published a piece back years ago on
mercy and justice and the pro slow gian
i presented on mercy and justice in the
courteous homo this last fall at a
satellite session of the American
Catholic philosophical association and
I'm going to be presenting this this
other thing so it's sort of a trip dish
of works that I'm eventually going to
develop into a short book on the issue
of the compatibility or the the the you
know the interpenetration of divine
justice in mercy in st. Anselm's thought
with a bit of comparative work to
previous thinkers and looking ahead to
later thinkers so the the residency up
there will last it's pretty sure to last
about a week or so you know given the
travel time but then after the residency
is over i'll also be staying up there
for the annual st. Anselm meta physics
colloquium this is a fairly small you
could call it a conference
it's really more of a workshop in which
a lot of great scholars from the local
area come you know some some pretty big
names in fact I had the good fortune of
meeting somebody who I had correspond
with years ago Oliver blah shut a major
Maurice blown del scholar the guy i
wrote my dissertation on race blondell
last time that I was there and it's
always you know some really stimulating
intense discussion of issues in
metaphysics which spill over into ethics
philosophy of nature social philosophy
epistemology and it's a great time they
always do a great job in hosting it and
you know a lot of the same people keep
going year after year so it's it's a way
for me to catch up with old friends and
colleagues as well so that's the
Institute stuff now I'm going to be
doing something a little bit different
than I've done with other sorts of
things like that you remember that last
year I was a visiting scholar at the
European graduate school but I didn't
really shoot in a video about that this
time I decided that what I ought to do
is I'm going to do some video blogging
about the trip up there what I'm doing
you know the kind of research that goes
on to give you a little glimpse into the
you know this sort of portion of the
life of the mind you can see to a
certain extent what what academic
scholars actually do and the conditions
in which they they work and the kinds of
things they get excited about so I
decided I'm going to shoot you know two
maybe two maybe for any somewhere in
between videos not every single day but
but you know at least some of the days
while I'm up there I'll do some talking
to my YouTube audience about the
research and how it's going and and
what's involved in any other interesting
stuff that comes up I'm also going to
hopefully do some interviews with some
of the main people who are
involved with the same handsome the
institute for st. Anselm studies because
I think that that could be interesting
for you viewers as well so there's going
to be some different video work going on
and if that takes off maybe you'll do
more stuff like that in the future we'll
see i also have a couple talks coming up
one is a public talk at the kingston
library on june thirteenth i'll be back
in kingston by that time and it will be
on the epicurean philosophers and their
philosophical tradition and there are
orientation towards anger part of the
understanding anger series so if you're
in the area and you want something
stimulating on a saturday morning stop
by and if you do introduce yourself let
me know you know who you are there's
also a conference that i'll be attending
where i'll be presenting a paper i'm not
sure whether I will be able to video
record it or not it's out in Long Island
I will be presenting on the 26 which is
a friday it's the Aquinas Leadership
Institute so it's it's mostly focused on
issues of leadership organizational
behavior but it's it's a it's a
conference applying philosophy to these
issues so it fits in very well with a
sort of consulting work that I do and I
will be talking about Thomas Aquinas
views on anger it's it's a his construe
love anger as being concerned with what
we call the difficult good and how it
fits in with issues of leadership and
organization so that'll be a lot of fun
i hope i get some great feedback on that
i'm also doing some more work on writing
and research i already mentioned the an
some related stuff there's the aquinas
paper that i need to actually get in
shape ready to present and i need to get
that Marcel paper finally hat you know
hammered out and sent off as long ago
promised you
haven't done a lot of work on the
Christian philosophy debates as of late
but it's something that I used to do a
lot of work on and so I'm looking
forward to you know spending more time
going back over those 1930s debates and
talking about Marcel's own role of it
how it fits in with is later philosophy
as far as video work goes you've got
quite a few things coming up like I said
I'm going to be pairing back video work
to about four videos per week which is
still quite a bit a lot of channels only
put out one video per week I've got to
actually three channels I haven't
released the third channel yet but
there's a you know quite a bit coming
out oh I have six half hour Hagel videos
that I'm on the hook for for this month
so I need to get cracking on that and
they're like I pointed out one of the
most difficult portions of the
phenomenology force in the understanding
so they take a little bit more time than
than normal because I've spent such
tightly re reading and rereading and
saying what what exactly is going on
here but it's good work to do there will
be more critical thinking fallacy videos
coming out this month I'm going to be
doing some some video blogging like I
said on ants on the interview the
epicurean epicurean is an anger session
for the understanding anger series will
be available and I'm also going to be
doing some core concept videos I've got
a ethics class that is starting for
marist actually today I opened the class
this last weekend but you know these
core concept videos I use them pretty
extensively in my my classes and I've
been teaching this online ethics class
and tweaking it for the last four years
from marist college and I you know each
time around I try to add some new
material some some new videos when
possible in one of the areas where I
don't have an awful lot right now as far
as the core concept videos go is
epicurus and the hedonist tradition so
I'm hoping to
to shoot some videos on that I've got to
do it before my class actually gets that
far in the semester so you know you can
look for those coming out later this
month as well so those are the things
coming up in this month that's what
happened last month quite a bit going on
as usual I probably won't be doing as
much blogging but i'll be spending a lot
more time on academic writing this month
and you know a lot more intensive
research time I hope all of you have a
good month and that's pretty much all
there is to say at this point